the MVP candidates through four weeks of
the Season Lamar Jackson well over 40
percent are running back nomination is
none other than New York Giants Russia
saquon Barkley oh he's back finally out
wide receiver we do have the reigning
defending fantasy football MVP of the
world Cooper cop himself drum roll
please
[Music]
Cooper cup it's about that difference
between Cooper Cup and the next best
wide receiver let's go ahead and get
into our rookie of the year now let's
first start talking about Breece Hall
the New York Jets running back Chris
olave from the Ohio State University the
Buckeye receiver closes out our top
three Rookie of the Year candidates
Garrett Wilson
I agree with you all it's Chris a Lobby
come on the guy is a top 10 receiver in
receiving yours and he's played four
games next category up we have our best
waiver wire pickup how about Jared Goff
leading the way so far Curtis Samuel
right behind him Romeo dubs on the up
and up
I'm gonna go with Curtis Samuel it's
funny we spent the entire offseason you
know trying to figure out who the next
Debo Samuel is going to be